what else can we hit on here man we get
a lot of asked a good question he said
break down some of that West Coast game
I could talk about yeah okay go ahead
talk about what's cooking
so uh I have a couple girlfriends that
are at a LA and what I learned and I
went out there myself and what I figured
out was that Los Angeles is very
dependent upon social circle games so
like California the whole state of
California the bars close at 2:00
but by like 1:30 they turn the lights on
they want you out because they need to
have the place closed down by two so
what I learned in LA when I was there
was that it's not like Vegas or Miami
where you can like party all night you
need to know people to get invited to a
how to get invited to like a mansion
party or whatever like on Hollywood
Hills whatever so the only people let's
keep a row that have access to that is
either you have clout or you're a hot
girl
so social circle is very important in LA
to get invited to like clubs and then
other thing too is that to get into the
top clubs you definitely got to know
people because there's such a high
concentration of celebrities there that
there
they don't need like the average
person's business you know I'm saying so
LA that's one thing I didn't like about
LA is that like it was very social
circle game dominated so if you're not
as somebody you don't have connections
you're it's just gonna be tough and
another thing too is that um like a lot
of girls like with these Hollywood
parties what they'll do is like the
manager of like a celebrity rap or
whatever maybe and I learned this like
girls have told me this that live in LA
this is exactly how it goes down they
get an invite like a DM on Instagram hey
such-and-such celeb is having a party at
this address at this time blah blah blah
not he doesn't give the address but like
he's interested you guys want to come
bring your friends and they're like yeah
they're like okay cool he'll give them
the address they'll show up and it's
only girls know guys can come and then
they'll make them sign NDA's all the
girls have to sign NDA's and then when
they get to the house they take all
their phones so they can't post anything
on social media whatever maybe they
bring them in the celeb is there with
all his friends whatever and then they
just party and then like you know that's
just how it is you know I know Dan
Bilzerian does this with NDA's and a
bunch of other celebs so LA is very whoo
you know New York City though is a
little bit different like New York City
is you got to pay to play and what I
mean by that is in New York City it's
not like Miami where you can go anywhere
and there's hot girls and a dive bar
like New York City if you go to a dive
bar you're gonna take it out it's gonna
be all do
so the only way you're gonna meet
attractive women in New York City is
you're gonna have to pay to get into the
top clubs like mr. purple one oak
you know bounce etc and if you're a guy
that as soon as you show up at the door
and it's like two or three of you
they're gonna try to you they're either
a gonna force you get a table spend a
couple hundred or thousands of dollars
or you're going to that's my ringtone
that's the gray rings oh man
so they're gonna make you pay a bunch of
money at the door or they're not gonna
let you in and say you're not on the
list so New York City is definitely like
you got to pay to have fun in New York
City where's like the thing I like about
Miami is you can land not know anybody
they still go to any club or bar and
still see attractive women versus like
in LA and New York you either have to
know people LA or New York you also have
to know people but you could pay your
way in New York City so those are big
differences I've noticed in night game
and those matrices mmm cool dude you got
some serious breakdowns here